- What's up blog?
Gary V. here.
Really excited about this episode.
Long day in Copenhagen,
did a bunch of content.
This first key note, which
was the first session there,
I thought it was extremely strong.
I think there's some
pretty remarkable insights,
and I hope you enjoy it, and here it is.
(upbeat techno theme music)
- I know many of you have
waited a long time for this,
I know that I have.
So I think we should
all just get on our feet
and put our hands together
and welcome Gary Vaynerchuk.
(audience clapping and cheering)
- Thank you, thank you for coming.
That was nice.
- [Host] That was nice!
- Yes, thank you guys,
thrilled to be here.
- [Host] You could get used to that, yeah?
To help the session get started,
some of you have prepared some questions.
So, let's get started with that.
Do we have the mic runners ready?
Okay, are you ready, Gary?
- [Gary] I'm always ready.
- [Host] Perfect!
- So, yes.
And are you ready?
- Yes!
- [Host] Okay, perfect.
Well, would you like to
say a little about yourself
before we start up?
- Yeah, I mean, for the people
in here who are not familiar,
I guess the best way for me
to quantify what I'm about is:
I'm a serial entrepreneur.
I was born in the former Soviet Union,
came to the U.S. as a kid.
And, you know, really invested
in Facebook, and Twitter,
and Uber, and Tumblr, and
did very well in investing.
Built my dad's liquor store
business in the late '90s
on the back of modern day
marketing and execution,
which at the time, for
the kids in the room,
was even having a website in 1996,
not thinking the Internet
was gonna be a fad.
And then, built businesses
on the back of email,
and Google AdWords, and then YouTube,
and then this whole social media run.
And I think a lot of what I'm
thinking about in this journey
we're about to take over four hours
between this Q & A session,
the key note I wanna deliver,
and other things we're doing is,
the more I think about it,
the more I realize how much
of it was mental perspective,
self-awareness, emotional intelligence.
The tactics are very important,
but they're incredibly commoditized.
How to run a Facebook ad,
or what a good deal on an influencer is,
is very different than
really reverse engineering
who you are, and putting your company,
or yourself more importantly,
in a position to succeed.
So you know, I think I'm an overdeveloped,
emotional intelligence entrepreneur.
Which is confusing because
my persona, my shtick,
my showmanship, speaks more to sales,
and more aggressive alpha dynamics.
But I would argue that
I'm dramatically more
in the listening business than
I am in the talking business,
if one ever had the time to
actually see what's going on.
- [Host] Perfect!
Well, let's get started then.
Mariah, are you in the room?
Yup, could we have a mic on her?
Edmariah, over here.
Back, in the back.
So Mariah will ask you her own question.
- Yup.
- It will come for you now.
- Hello Gary.
- How are you?
- I have been so excited being here so --
- Thank you.
- I would really like to ask you
what is your number one marketing advice
and I'm thinking about online marketing.
- So whether it's online
or offline, Marta,
I would tell you that the thing
that has been most interesting to me
coming from entrepreneurship
or liquor store retail or
the really entrepreneurial
Silicon Valley start up world
to now being in the last seven years
spending a lot of times
with the biggest brands in the world,
global brands.
I'm stunned that people
are not consumer centric.
I would tell you my number
one marketing advice
is to be empathetic.
Everybody's so selfish when they market.
They want the customer to
do what they want them to do
instead of the way I think about it,
which is more counter punching,
which is listen to what
your customer's doing
that you're trying to sell and market to
and formulate a marketing
strategy around that.
And so for me the reason I today,
push Facebook so much,
is 'cause that scale,
whether it B to B of B to C,
Facebook is under-priced attention
that the masses are paying attention to.
And if you become an amazing practitioner
in the pictures, written
words, audio and video
of that medium,
you win.
So when people watch television
or listen to radio or read magazines,
they need to be good at that craft.
My number one marketing advice is empathy
and then skill set around
once you realize where they are,
and to me in November 2017,
that is to become the disproportionate
best Facebook marketer that you could be.
- Thank you.
(applause)
- [Host] Now Helen Bertrop, where are you?
Do we have Helen?
- Yeah, I'm here.
- How are you?
- Hi Gary.
- Good to see you today.
- Great to see you.
- So I am actually in the
Facebook marketing business
and sometimes my clients,
they say something around,
they don't want to market
themselves too much --
- Personally?
- Yeah personally, maybe
they're like therapists
or they run some causes or whatever and --
- Or ugly.
- Uh. (nervous chuckle)
- I'm kidding, I'm kidding,
I'm kidding, I'm kidding.
Go ahead, go ahead.
- I hope not.
- But sometimes people have this feeling
that they don't want to --
- Yes.
- Be too much in other people's face.
- Do you have advice for that situation?
- I would tell you
that you should not convince them of that.
Because I'm so out there,
people are always like,
okay, should I build a
personal brand for my business?
You know, should I be in their feed
five times a day, every day?
I think the answer is,
not necessarily, right?
I think to me,
I think it's reverse
engineering the individual.
You know now, if your
business is selling yourself,
as a fitness instructor or a lawyer
or a financial investor
or a real estate agent,
you're gonna wanna be out there, right?
And if the question is more
about the difference
between alpha American DNA
where you're out in front
and other parts of the world
where people are more reserved,
you know, at some level
it's very difficult
to make somebody do something
they're not comfortable with.
They'll never be good at it.
I wanna remind everybody,
some of the biggest
companies in the world,
you don't even know the name of the CEO,
let alone what she or he looks like.
So, just because there are
certain people taking advantage,
and others of the opportunity,
building personal brand
as a branding mechanism
to build their business,
it doesn't mean it's
the only way to do it.
And so I never try to convince people
to build their personal
brand or be out there more.
I remind them that if they're
good at it and enjoy it,
is it a credibly owned and controllable IP
that is unbelievably scalable,
but I would tell you that I don't think
that this is a one size fits
all situation and environment.
And so I'm not overly passionate
that everybody needs to
build their personal brand,
but there is significant
upside if you can.
Cool.
(applause)
- [Host] Vitvas, upstairs?
- Very nice.
- [Host] Run, run for us, run.
- That was quick.
- Thank you.
- Hey.
Oh, okay, don't worry, I'm calm, I'm sure.
There we go.
- Okay.
Thank you so much for the
enormous amount of content
that you provide the regular people with.
That's quite surprising.
- Thank you.
- And I have a question for you.
How do you start to market the service
that people who currently don't see
as something that they would benefit from?
- First you really have to wrap your head
around humility, right?
My entire career has been
around this question.
When I first got into the wine business,
I tried to make Americans
drink Spanish wines,
New Zealand wines.
You know, wines from
obscure places in France
like the Mataron and Languedoc.
And because I saw that
being my opportunity,
I felt that I was a
disproportionately good marketer
and storyteller,
that was more arbitrage and
me bringing these brands
and these regions to the surface.
As you can imagine,
when I started talking about social media
in 2007 and eight and nine, you know,
as a lot of you know,
most companies still don't
believe that social media
is ROI positive.
That is nine years later
and so the first thing I would tell you is
too many people get frustrated
when they're going in
to this kind of world.
If the market doesn't
perceive the value of it,
that means that you're
making a bet that it's true
and that over the next 24
to 48 months, they will.
Because if it's longer than that,
you'll be out of business
by the time you're proven to be right.
You know, it's not fun to be right
and not get the benefits of being right
because you were so dramatically early.
Like cool, I understand that you know
that VR is gonna happen and
virtual reality's gonna happen.
The problem is it's gonna take 20 years
before it's at the scale that may benefit
for the way that people are
building their businesses today.
So, I would first say humility
and then you need to go on a
hardcore education pounding.
How many people are here have
been following my content
for more than five years?
Raise your hands.
So these 12, 15 people,
I've been sayin' the same
fuckin' shit for a decade.
Every day, for free, at scale,
more than any goddamn human
being on the mobile device.
And I still have to do it every day,
all day, to everybody.
And so it's enormous patience and empathy
and make sure that your
timing isn't too far ahead.
And then finally just continuously looking
for under-priced attention.
Because you won't be able to afford
to tell your story in overpriced
attention for too long
if you're selling something
people aren't ready for.
And then you've gotta really
pound the value prop, right?
I'm not into social media
'cause I like technology
and gadgets and I'm a technologist
and I think it's fun or cool.
I'm in it because I think
attention is the number one asset
if you wanna build a business
and I'd look for where it's
under-priced and overpriced.
And when I'd speak to it,
I speak in business terms
which eventually get people
to understand it in business terms,
not because of the altruistic,
it's nice to reply to somebody on Twitter.
And so, I would make sure that
you're speaking the language
of the individuals that
you're trying to convert
and that's the framework
you have to live in.
And this model has the most upside,
but also has the most graveyards.
- Okay.
- Thank you.
(applause)
- [Host] Then it's Kai.
Over here, can we have a mic on him?
Thank you.
He's fast.
- Hi Gary, welcome to Denmark.
- Thank you for having me.
- Um, like I guess a lot
of other people in here,
I am a entrepreneur with
very small business.
I have three employees.
I'm in the creative business,
I'm a jeweler and that
means that obviously,
I'm wearing a lot of hats.
- Yes.
- We call them.
So my question is given all
the things that I need to do,
what percentage of time should
I allocate for marketing?
- Versus what else?
- Versus everything.
In my case, talking to customers,
designing, creating jewelry,
handling my employees, everything admin,
decoration, you name it.
- I mean I think for,
how many people here are entrepreneurs?
Amazing.
So you have the audacity
to wanna live life on your terms.
And so I need,
hold the mic.
Let her hold that for a second, my friend.
Thank you.
One more time,
hands in the air.
We have the audacity to
live life on our terms.
The percentage of
successful entrepreneurs,
ones that can make a living
and live their lives on their own back,
not in the company structure,
is quite low.
The percentage of those that
amass the kind of wealth
that everybody thinks
they're going to amass
when they get into entrepreneurship
is even smaller than that.
The answer to your question my friend,
is all of it, all the
time, always, forever.
(cheers, applause)
And so to that point
and that's collecting
the energy in this room,
I think we all understand.
You're in a boat,
there's marketing, there's your employees,
there's sales, there's the product.
If the jewelry isn't good,
who gives a shit if the marketing's good,
it's not right.
There's all these things
and we're all in a boat
and here pops a hole
and you've got to go put your finger in it
and then there's one over here
and your toe and then
finally it fixes and good.
Now two more over here,
we're in the firefighter business.
I am in constant anxiety.
I have to be here for the next four hours.
When I get off,
America has started today.
My office is in motion.
We're five, six hours ahead.
There's a lot that's about
to happen in my business
in the next five hours and this is fun
and I'm obsessed with the admiration
and I can't wait to take
selfies and high-fives
and answer questions and
give a great keynote.
And I'm so excited to
be in this amazing town
and meet you guys and
it's fucking incredible.
Yet, the second it's over,
from the high of the high
of people traveling hours
or I change their lives,
I take my phone and I have 17 headaches.
This person quit and this client's mad
and this didn't go well
and this is a problem,
and (clicking sound),
everything, always, forever
because we have the audacity
to want it in this way
which is the best way to have it
for a human if you're capable.
(applause)
- [Host] And let's find the capabilities
to find the next question.
Casper, here.
- Hello Gary.
- Hello my man.
- I do watch what you do
and love what you say.
- I like it.
- But still I have a question.
I have a lifestyle brand
and a DJ collection.
So I'm a DJ.
I'm playing after hours today.
So my question is
my own like DJ promotion or
for me to, yeah.
- I see it.
I would probably do it.
If there's nothing that stands out
to why not doing it under your name,
I would do it under your name.
Because personal will always
over index versus a logo.
And I think that we are
now in the day and age
where people are okay with understanding
people are complete people
and have multiple things going on.
I remember the early days of this
people would have like a very
different life on Facebook
than they had on LinkedIn.
You know?
And I would always laugh
because they thought they
were tricking somebody.
Like, we all know.
You know it's funny now that I'm a parent,
my daughter is doing a
lot of things that I did
and at eight, I thought it worked.
Now I just realized my
mom was letting me do it
and laughing at me.
(laughter)
And that's how I think about why it's okay
to mix personal and professional.
You're not tricking anybody,
that you're so professional
with a nice picture with a tie on LinkedIn
while you're throwing up on Instagram.
(laughter)
So I think we should just embrace it
and so I think the personal part
will always over-index over a logo.
(talking off mic)
(applause)
Good.
- [Host] All right.
Now it's time for Yasper.
Yes? Over here.
- Hey Gary.
- How are you?
- I'm good.
So I have a micro question.
- You don't wanna stand up?
- I can stand up if you want.
- Respect.
Let's clap it up for him.
(clapping)
- So I have a micro question.
What kind of content should
the world's leading VR
physical therapy company be
putting out on social media?
(chuckling)
- First of all Yasper,
you need to be putting out content
that makes people understand
what the fuck that means.
(host chortles)
Right?
- Makes sense.
- And I'm making a joke,
but you know that's exact,
like that's similar to two questions ago.
Your job right now is to get
people to even understand
what that is.
I mean, you know,
this is a room that has a chance
of understanding what that means.
The 99% of normals have no
idea what you're talking about.
I think a lot of us that are
fortunate enough to understand
the cutting edge of
marketing or technology
have one certain language,
but then there's the rest of the world.
The ones we're trying to sell to,
the ones that don't overthink their copy
on a Instagram photo.
Like, the normals.
And so for the normals
and even for this group,
we've gotta really wrap
our head around what VR,
you know, physical therapy is.
I think we can theoretically understand.
But I think the first thing
is you have to put out content
to make us even comfortable
that it's not a jankee experience.
Because I think the
ones that understand it,
understand that it's got a
ways to go, technology wise.
There's a lot of things that are there
and so I would just overeducate.
I think, you know,
I don't know if you follow me,
but when I talk about
documenting versus creating --
- Yeah, we're doing that.
Been blogging for like the last year.
- Huge.
- Everything we've done.
- Huge and so then
you've gotta figure out,
if you're doing that,
you're three fourths of the way there.
Now you've gotta figure
out two core things.
Is it interesting?
And do you know how to distribute it?
- Yeah.
- You know?
- Number two was down,
but one is like you're talking about.
It's the education thing that's maybe.
We're doing the storytelling,
but like more explainer
videos or where are we at?
- You know I think, again,
it's a lot of these similar answers like
you need to make entertainment content
and informational content.
You're gonna need them both
in a business like this.
And so I would just keep,
you know, creating at scale.
It's just imperative.
And then I would also think a lot
about influencers, you know?
I mean if you've got good, you know,
tracking on what's going on on
Instagram or other platforms
and you would get the luxury
of having somebody maybe,
tear an ACL or something in that nature
and you can get an influencer
to go through rehab with you,
I think there could be an
incredible narrative there
that could bring disproportionate
awareness to your product.
- Uh yeah, makes sense. Thanks.
- Cool. You got it.
(applause)
- [Host] Now it's time for Stian.
Oh, over here.
- Yup, yeah, he's up there.
Hey.
- Hi Gary.
- How are you?
- Very good.
- Good.
- First of all,
thank you so much for,
I follow you from 2014.
- Thank you.
- Got a video with you in '99,
talking about different
context and channels.
So my question is actually,
had a couple of questions.
I'm a speaker and I'm
a consultant in product
and file management
and I do it for a year.
My background is for movie producing
and since the new think,
I'm sort of a one man army,
as many people I guess.
And it's really hard with sometimes
with allocating the time
because I'm focused primarily
on content, on delivering to customers
and to sell directly, like
reaching out to customers.
But I'm also super
curious about influencers
and I never done it before,
but I was just wondering
if it will make any sense
to allocate time where
I am right now with the
spending some of my time
on the influencers market
and trying to reach out
to people on Instagram
or maybe LinkedIn even better.
So I just wanted to hear what's
your thoughts about that.
- Well I think, look again
at the youth that you're at
at the ambition that you have.
You know, one thing that always
scares me about my narrative
is people always ask me,
how much do I sleep or am I
an advocate of not sleeping,
'cause I'm not.
I think people should sleep
six, seven, eight hours,
depending on your body.
I'm a huge advocate in
"what the fuck are you doing
the other 18 hours?", right?
And so when I hear your question,
the answer's "of course you should."
You know you should.
You know you should test.
Everybody here should spend
meaningful amounts of time
testing everything, everything.
You know, that's what
you're supposed to be doing,
'Cause you don't know the
answer for your specific nuance
if LinkedIn or a podcast or
influence or marketing or,
you know, you don't know
if that's gonna be the turning point.
And what you're doing is
you're doing too many things.
People are keeping their time precious
when it's their biggest asset.
People are not reinvesting
money back into their business
'cause they wanna buy dumb shit.
People are not trying
things because if they fail,
they worry about what other
people think about that failure.
And so they're, we're all, you know,
the answer is yes,
to everything.
Literally, fuck it.
I'm like yes and I can leave
and go fluckin' fly to L.A. right now.
Because the next three hours is "yes".
(audience laughs)
- (snickers) It is. It's yes.
So, of course you should.
Like, what are you doing
for 18 hours a day?
Find an hour and do it
for an hour every day
to get to the answer.
And then also understand that
the first 10 times you do it,
it might not be right.
Because it's like,
you know I always talk about the ROI.
People are like, "what's
the ROI of influencers or VR
the ROI of those 10 hours
reaching out to influencers?".
The ROI of a basketball is
very different to people.
To me it's nothing,
to LeBron James, it's a billion dollars.
So all this stuff works.
It's "are you good at it?",
is a whole 'nother question.
So it's not just the ROI of trying it
then you got to get good at it.
Nothing you're good at right now,
you were so great out the
first time you tried it.
So, of course, man.
Like everything that's happening,
you need to figure out how
it works for your business,
B to B, B to C, personal brand.
The question is,
what are you doing with
your time, you know?
And so that's why I get mad at people
who wanna be an entrepreneur
and watch four hours of
Netflix a weekend or,
and by the way,
people need escapism,
you need to check out,
you need to rest,
you have to be in a mental place.
But the scrutiny that we
have to put on our time
as young entrepreneurs, you know,
it's just time or money.
Talent is the variable that sits in here,
but the assets that you're sitting with
in the beginning are time
and then you amass money and
then you can use the money
to save time and you're
just going back and forth.
And everybody wants these big dreams
and they're not willing to
work at the level they need to
and that's the advantage they have.
So, fuck yes, you should.
- I just want to wrap it up
and that's the biggest inspiration
I got from you since 2014.
Just to cut off the crap
and just fucking work.
So thank you so much.
- You're welcome and I
just wanna say one thing.
If that's your ambition,
you can work 10 hours a week.
If you're happy, I'm happy.
But don't go running around saying
you're gonna build a 17
million dollar business
and think you're gonna do
that on 25 hours a week.
That person doesn't exist.
Anybody you know who's
built something meaningful,
has worked for it.
I know people have inherited money,
but they're not the one that built it.
Anybody you know that built something,
put in the work.
There's just no shortcut.
It's like working out.
You can't think about pushups.
(light laughter)
Good.
(applause)
- Thank you.
- [Host] And before we
take the next question,
you can begin to wonder if
you want to ask Gary something
because we got a few
more questions prepared.
But then it's up to you, the audience.
- Awesome.
- [Host] So, yeah?
In a while we'll set you free.
Jonas.
- Yeah I'm here.
- Over here?
- How are you Jonas?
- Oh shit, I can't believe
I'm talking to you, man.
(laughs)
(audience laughs)
- Don't worry brother,
it's gonna be okay.
(applause)
- All right, so my question is
in the very, very early
stage of the startup,
my first startup,
- Yep.
- And on the very, very slight budget.
- The first thing to focus on,
the most important thing and how to.
- (sighs) There's so much brother, so --
- I'm so overwhelming,
that's why I'm asking you.
- Of course, I mean I think a lot
of what I just talked about is true.
The biggest advantage you
have right now is your time.
It's your number one asset.
You're young,
you should have plenty of energy,
you're hungry,
you're ambitious, great.
You need to work every
goddamn minute you can.
It's the single biggest thing you've got.
The other thing is
you need to figure out how
to get leverage, right?
So, you need to figure
out what does that mean?
So, what's the business?
- Right now it's a
website selling posters.
- It's a what, brother?
- A web shop selling posters.
- A web shop selling posters?
- Yeah, yeah.
- So, you're a web shop,
when you say posters,
you, physical?
- Yeah.
- Okay, so you're trying
to sell them to people?
- Yeah.
- And how much does it
cost you to make them?
- 10 bucks, right now.
It's in very small pieces again, package.
- So, one thing that I'm a
huge fan of in the beginning
is doing a lot of work for free.
And people get very mad
at me for this advice.
I don't know why.
'Cause they debate me in theory
instead of actually
ever living a business.
You know, one of the things
that you're looking for is awareness.
You need to let people know you exist.
One of the great ways to do that
is to do free work for
people that have awareness.
You're giving them work,
they're giving you awareness.
So I would have a hardcore
strategy in the market
that you're trying to fulfill,
to do free work and reach
out to the companies
or individuals and say,
I wanna do this for you for
free because I like your work.
This is the kind of work we do,
would you like it?
And by the way,
I have a thousand people
a day offer me "free"
and I don't take them up on it
because the value exchange
of the time is not worth it.
So just 'cause you even offer it for free
doesn't mean they'll take you up on it.
But the number one thing I would do first,
if I was your partner,
I was like,
cool, let's get side jobs,
let's sell shit.
Let's do something else to amass dollars,
let's borrow money,
let's rent money,
let's raise capital or
let's take our money
that we have together
to do as much free work
for the biggest celebrity,
the biggest athlete,
the biggest business, the coolest thing,
the coolest festival,
the coolest brand, free,
as long as we're getting
awareness out of it,
to build our brand to
then create deal flow.
- All right, do you
think that's possible to
with a very tight budget.
So, you're meaning that I
have to work free for them
or then I have to provide
some of my products
for them, for free?
- Both.
- Both?
- Free and free.
- Yeah.
- Which could mean that you
may have to get a side job
at night or borrow money
or have a separate business all together,
but, or do services for
other people at low costs.
Like, what I get surprised
that people don't understand,
is what are the alternatives?
Like, why are you asking me this question?
You're asking 'cause you don't
have the answer right now,
because there's not that many alternatives
when you don't have a lot of money
and nobody knows what
the fuck your product is.
(snickers)
- Yeah, exactly.
- Right, so, entrepreneurship is super fun
and cool on Instagram,
but in real life, it sucks shit.
(laughter)
So, you know, doing shit
for free is not fun.
Go ahead.
- I'm just saying that I have
a part-time job right now.
- That's good.
- Yeah, and I'm working
on this after hours and --
- Great, so you know the money --
- You just want me to use all the money
for the business, right?
- Yes, so don't buy another thing.
No more nice jacket.
- That's from my mom, so.
- Respect.
(laughter)
(applause)
That's good. That's good.
Yeah, I think a small
company that makes posters
number one arbitrage,
is to make posters for free
for things that will give them awareness.
When people are like,
"who made that poster?",
if your brand's there,
things of that nature,
that is your number one move
you can do when you're tiny.
And so you just need to
be able to afford that,
including selling the nice
jacket that your mom gave you.
(laughter and applause)
- Thank you man.
- You're welcome.
- [Host] Okay, Miguel, where are you?
- But you know what?
Real quick because it's a funny moment,
it's just very true.
Like, there's a reason
immigrants over-index in success.
That's the kind of shit they do.
They don't buy anything.
They live in a place that has
a shitty house for seven years
and save every dollar
even though they could've
moved out two years earlier
or four years earlier.
Non-entrepreneurs, as soon
as they get a little money,
buy dumb shit,
instead of putting it
back into their business.
And so like, it seems like a funny joke,
but like, when you have no options,
you have no options.
Like it's not miraculously gonna happen
and everybody got tricked because
of venture capital funding
and everybody thinks they're
gonna writer a business plan
on paper and go out and
find some miraculous VC
and then they complain,
well in Denmark and Norway
they don't have good VCs,
but Silicon Valley,
Silicon Valley's a fuckin' bitch too.
They'll take the meeting,
but not gonna give you money either.
And so, we need to be
smart and more practical.
That's real life.
- [Host] Thank you.
- You're welcome.
(applause)
- [Host] Okay, Miguel where are you?
Down here, can we get a mic now?
- Smack in the middle.
- [Host] Yeah.
- Hey Miguel.
- Oh my god.
Gary V. is in the house and
I'm about to ask a question.
- Yes you are.
- Okay, hi Gary, is it possible --
- How are you?
- Very good.
If you're about to open a
trampoline park in Copenhagen
in around four month,
how would you approach the marketing
until the opening and after?
- Okay, let's start with the four months.
Is that an arbitrary thing
or is that a 100% locked in?
Like, why four months?
- Had a meeting with the owner, the boss,
yesterday and he wants me to run it,
but he want to do the
marketing and I ask him,
what would you do?
Facebook ads and Google ads and that's it.
- That's what you asked him?
- Yes, he would do the marketing
with Facebook ads and Google ads.
- And that's what he wants to do?
- That's it.
- Okay.
- And what would you do?
- I'm very high on that.
You know, I kind of did a
little bit of homework on
like the attention arbitrage in Copenhagen
before I got here.
I think that's cool.
I would just add influencer
marketing on top of that.
I think there's a lot
of Instagram, Snapchat,
Facebook personalities that could bring
disproportionate attention
to this and are under-priced.
It's incredible to me that
there's a lot of individuals
in the Copenhagen metro area and suburbs
that you could invite for free,
that even have 719 fans or 3,000 fans
on some of these platforms,
that the ROI of you giving it
to them for free for the photo
is worth it for you from
a business standpoint.
So I would say those three and then look,
it's very abstract
to say you're gonna do
Facebook and Google.
Really understanding the
content that you need to make
in a Facebook environment
is incredibly important.
So you can waste $10,000 on
Facebook in a month very quickly
if you don't know what you're doing.
And so, just make sure
that you guys have a deep understanding
on the kind of content that will convert.
Are you trying to,
and then also the four months before
and the four months after.
In the four months before,
I would drive them to a landing
page that has a Google form
that fills out so that
you can use that data
to re-market when you open,
than after the fact,
you're driving them to a place
where frictionless, you know,
conversion to the tickets
or the packages that you're selling.
- What about something like,
make people, you know, the
journey of now we're here,
now they're manufacturing the
trampoline parts in Hanover --
- You know this is the thing
similar to the VR physical service.
This is the thing
that I wanna make sure
everybody understands,
'cause a lot of you are paying
attention to what I'm doing
and I'm a believer.
I'm a believer in the
"documenting the journey".
Instead of creating.
I just wanna remind everybody
that there are millions of
documentaries made every year,
but only 13 of them are things
that people wanna watch.
So, yes, I believe it,
but can you and can he and can others
make a great --
- Yes.
- Documentary on the journey
that makes people really wanna watch
and fall in love with
the characters, you and,
That is a real challenge,
but if you can do it,
yes, I'm super interested in
it and I wanna remind everybody
that's now thinking about this
first time they're hearing it,
there's so much young talent out there
that just wanna get their, you know,
their first work out
there as a videographer
or as a post editor.
I believe that everybody here
can hire two to three
incredible, creative interns,
pay them very little,
but their ROI is the work
and they get a body of work.
And that's an incredible
opportunity for both parties.
We've never had people that
have been editing on Youtube
since they were six years old
and are now 17 and producing
this kind of quality, post production.
That is not the world we grew up in.
And so, I think yes,
and keep in mind that you might be able
to grab the extra hands.
Even for poster, you know like,
the fact that you can get
somebody "to work for free"
because for her the
documentation output is a project
she can point to if she
chooses to take that risk
'cause she has the same mindset
as you to "work for free".
I think there's a lot
of creators out there
that are looking for opportunities,
minimum wage, free and
obviously there's laws
and you'll have to navigate
the reality of what you can do,
but very low cost, high quality creators
are in the system right now.
Another thing for you to think about.
Look, for sure, if you could make a Vlog
of the road leading up to this,
but I'm telling you right now brother,
it's hard to get people to
get really excited and watch.
So I don't want you to disproportionately
put too much energy into it
or be thoughtful and go all in
for six to eight weeks and if you don't,
you know, you've got
to be smart about that.
Can't be ideological about
documenting versus creating.
Can't be ideological about anything.
You know, theory is only
as good as the execution
that creates the result that you want.
Things that I believe
in change by the minute
if I don't like the way the
cadence of the attention
or the platforms are evolving.
So my religion is never
what's talked about last week
or last year.
My religion is what's
happening right this minute
in the creative and
distribution opportunity
of communications to create the donation,
the voting for my candidate,
the opening of my
trampoline park, you know.
I worry that people that follow
me think that these things
are set in stone 'cause they've
not been carefully watching
the last ten years
where I will change my point of view
on anything other than
if I think your attention
is in a place that's under-priced,
that's where I wanna be.
- Thanks a lot.
- You got it.
(applause)
- [Host] Now for Maria Elaine.
Where are you?
Here? Can we get a mic on her down here?
- Right here.
- Here. Perfect.
- Hi.
- I'd like to ask you what the one thing
that you make sure to do every day
to keep strengthening
your online performances?
- To deploy gratitude
that the seven people
I love the most are healthy.
- Okay.
- I mean that's the real
answer that I'm not sure
if it brings anybody any value
or maybe it brings a lot
of people a lot of value.
That's the truth.
Like, none of this works
unless I'm in the right,
you know, grateful, passionate,
excited about it standpoint.
'Cause all this shit is hard.
And so for me, all of this is mindset.
There's no tactic.
There's no double checking
the copy on my Facebook post.
There's no updating the
picture on Instagram.
There's no looking at all
the replies on Twitter.
All of that is so secondary
to "am I in a good place"
to do the amount of work that is required
to do more, more, more, more, more,
yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
It's why I'm so fearful right
now about entrepreneurship
because I think a lot
of people are doing it
'cause it's cool or it seems cool.
And it's so hard and so
lonely and exposes you so much
that I want people in the right mindset.
So there's no tactic I do every day
other than consume and listen.
I read my email.
I look at the replies on Twitter.
I read all the replies from
the night before on Instagram
from my pictures.
I'm very qualitative.
I don't care how many likes or shares.
I don't care about it
as much about the data.
I understand it. I see it.
But I'm spending a lot more
time on the gray, the vibes
that I get from the
comments and engagement
of the community to give me
an indicator of what's working
and what's not working.
Like a performer that does,
it's kind of why I'm
a good public speaker.
I'm, right now, creating context
on what you guys are interested in
and it's already formulating my keynote
that's gonna come in an hour
based on this Q & A session.
That's good.
That's what makes me good at what I do.
I do that with my creative,
with my businesses.
To be very frank,
with my whole fuckin' life.
- Thank you.
- You're welcome.
(applause)
- [Host] Maria Lucia, where are you?
- Hi Gary. I'm here.
- Hi.
- Thank you for visiting Copenhagen.
- Thanks for having me.
- So, when we talk about
success, like in general,
what do you define as your
absolutely personal success?
- That's interesting.
Um, you know, for me I don't think
about my absolute personal success
in the micro or the short term.
I think about my ultimate
personal success in the long term.
So, somewhere in about 15 to 20 years
when I have a tremendous read
on who my two children
are as human beings,
that will be a very
big judgment day for me
on my personal success.
In 25 years when a intern named Cathy
that starts today is
running a huge business
and she learned at Vayner
Media the right things to do
to build a huge business,
that will be my personal success.
Right now I'm living out Sasha
and Tamara's personal success.
Right now I'm a by-product
of what my parenting
and my upbringing and my nuances.
My personal success has
a little bit more to go
and I think that's how I think about it.
And as long as I am daily acting
on that long term legacy North Star
and that everything that
comes out of my mouth
and everything that I do
spends disproportionate amount of time
on how Misha and Zander
and the rest of my family
and my employees are affected by it
and what it sets up for them,
that's basically how I think about.
I live my life only,
only based on what people are
saying behind my back, right?
You know, it's interesting right?
It's basically my framework, you know.
People are always like,
man, he's so nice.
I'm nice because when I
stop to take one more selfie
and say hello and look you in the face
and listen to your question,
that's what you're gonna
say about me when I'm gone.
And so I,
success for me is not in the short term.
It's just, you know, to me,
playing the game is success,
waking up in the morning is success,
being able to be who I am is success.
That's what I love about entrepreneurship.
You're in control.
But the absolute personal,
you know, judgement
is a long, long way away.
You know it's very interesting for me,
I apologize.
It's very interesting for me right now
what's happening in the world
that people are getting exposed.
A whole lot of people are being taken down
and I love that.
I love it because the
truth should be undefeated.
I don't, you know, I like that.
I like when merit wins,
when the truth wins.
And so for some us that are
living our lives that way,
this is very exciting times.
(applause)
- Thank you.
- You're welcome.
- [Host] Daniel, yeah?
- Hey Gary.
- How are you Daniel?
- Good. I've been watching
your Q & A, "Ask Gary"
and try to make my own
version of it and --
- What's it called?
- S & P integration Q & A.
- Understood.
- So it's a car technical
and that's my challenge here
about how do I both make it,
well technical, how do
we present these things
and as you talked about earlier here
about make it a bit
more entertaining or --
- Don't, you know, if you're
gonna make a documentary
which comes across as a film,
there's got to be an entertainment value
because the structure of a film
or documentary is escapism.
We're there to get caught up in the story
so we don't have to think
about the real world,
that's why we like music, sports and film.
When you're doing something technical,
you're in the utility education business.
It does not have to be entertaining.
- Okay.
- You don't come across as
the most entertaining dude
I've ever seen.
(laughter)
Like I'm being frank.
Guess what though?
Guess what?
And I'm not razzing or making a joke,
I need you to understand
why this is important.
If you fuckin' know your craft,
and you know what the
fuck you're talking about,
it's not gonna matter
how fuckin' charismatic
or funny you are,
you will win on your merit.
You just might need to
be extremely patient
because when there's small niches,
it takes time to hit any critical mass
'cause usually there is no critical mass.
And the way you surround your team
with people that don't understand
is you find people that do understand.
- Okay.
- You know, there's no --
- So that will be the intern or whatever.
- That's right.
When I built Wine Library for people
that worked on the floor
that knew about wine,
they needed to know about wine.
Like, you know, there's plenty
people that I saw and like,
oh, she's an amazing salesperson,
but then when I ask her
about Chateauneuf du Pape,
if she didn't know what it was,
that wasn't gonna cut it.
Because the business I was in,
you expected to walk in the store
and you had questions
and you needed answers
and it was important.
So I don't think you should run
away into the entertainment.
I think you should triple
down into technical,
utility and knowledge.
'Cause that wins too.
- Okay.
- You know?
It may not get you millions
of followers on Instagram,
but that's not what
you're trying to achieve.
You're trying to achieve
what you're trying to achieve
and so I think that that's great.
And I would triple down on the depth,
not the width.
- Okay, so just more technical content.
- And then remember,
audio, written, video.
Have you had to take a step back
and be self aware about which platform
you're best at communicating
is very important
and then understanding going forward,
just like yes, yes, yes, all of them,
all of you are going to
have to produce content
in written, audio and video
form to be relevant in the noise
that is coming in 2022.
'Cause you have to let the consumer pick
which medium is best for them
and you have to be everywhere
to really win.
I mean, you can't be
everywhere right away,
I get it.
But you have to wrap your head
around that and as for me,
somebody who could not put
three sentences together
that make any cohesive sense,
I get to hire a ghostwriter
who is listening right now to this video
and transcribing it and
then is gonna call me
and ask me five more questions
and I'm gonna answer them
and that's how I make my
LinkedIn and medium posts.
- Mmm. Okay.
- And at first I couldn't afford that.
So I had to give up on
writing and had to wait.
And so like, we all go
through these journeys,
but you know, you've
gotta really give thought
to the mediums too.
You could have a very
successful, super niche podcast
where you're just talking this stuff out
and the 1800 people
you're trying to reach,
700 of them listen to the podcast,
you will win.
If that's how narrow your world is.
- True. Thanks.
- You're welcome.
(applause)
- [Host] And now it's your turn.
So do we have the first up?
Yeah? Yeah.
- Pick me, pick me.
- He's quick.
- Hi, how are you doin'?
Simon Steven.
- How are you?
- So, actually I don't
have a question for you.
I've been following you a couple of years.
You've given me so many
ideas and thought awakenings
that I thought, man I owe you, big time.
But there's no way I can
pay you back at the moment
so I thought I'll give you something
that might bring you a little bit of joy.
And I know your background
into wine quite a bit now,
but I just realized that you
drink a lot of white wine.
- I am.
- But still.
(light laughter from audience)
So, I'm bringing with me a
Pierre Long Chateauneuf Du Pape.
- Very nice.
- From 2011.
I hope you like it.
It's what I can give you
as just a way of saying, "Thank you, man".
- It's very nice. Please.
- [Host] Give him a hand.
(applause)
- Real pleasure.
Thank you man.
Thank you so much.
(applause)
You know what's amazing about life?
The fact that I was just giving an analogy
of wine store knowledge.
And of all the wines in the world,
that I used Chateauneuf
du Pape as the example,
which is pretty esoteric.
And for that to be the wine?
Like that's when I'm like
the universe is looking at me
and saying, "keep going", you know?
(applause)
It's interesting.
- [Host] And we have one more over here.
Casper, behind you.
Yeah, thank you.
- Cool, hi Gary.
- How are you?
- Guys, real quick, just so you know,
between the other Q & A and the keynote
and the fact that we're covering so much,
I've made a new decision.
I'm gonna answer every
single person's question
in this conference.
So you better get way more extrovert
and start raising your hands
because I'm gonna
systematically pick on you
over the next three hours.
Go ahead.
- Hi Gary.
- How are you?
- My name is Vasille.
I've been watching your
content for more than a year,
actually saw you live in
the Bucharest in Branmines
if you --
- Yes.
- Remember that.
- I sure do.
- Also possibility to
ask you a question there
and just wanna say, you know,
thank you so much for
everything you've been done.
And in Bucharest I asked,
I shared my success as
well as a entrepreneur
where I was successful
building E-commerce store
with influence and marketing.
- I remember.
- For DMing, 100, 200 people.
I remember.
- And also my journey on
the Fiverr.com platform.
And so you know, interesting fact
that after that I saw
the keynote you posted
and it brought so much
attention to my Fiverr profile.
It started getting a lot
of, you know, context.
So I just wanna say, you know,
thank you so much for this.
- You're welcome.
It was incredible amount of opportunity.
- Good.
- And from this, you know, freelancing,
I was able to build a as a
social media marketing agency,
you know, on Fiverr.
And my question to you is,
I started to work on my personal branding
and I just got invited to some conference,
business conference to speak
and I wanna ask you,
if I start continue to, you
know, expand personal branding,
would help me get bigger clients?
- Yes.
- You know we've uh --
- Like bigger companies.
- Yes.
- Or would it also just
bring like audience to you,
like you have a large
audience following you.
So do you, what do you have, you know,
opinion on that.
Working personal brand to --
- Both are gonna happen.
- Okay.
Thank you.
- That's my opinion Visalle.
- Thank you.
- Like, both will happen, right?
And so what will happen is
you'll get bigger clients
because what you're
doing is building brand.
I love it when people get
cynical about personal brand,
'cause I know there's cynicism around it.
All it, you know,
if you don't like the word personal brand,
let's call it something else.
Reputation.
Yes, if you have a bigger reputation,
things will happen, right?
What will happen is on
the personal brand side,
fans or audience, not clients,
what will happen is opportunity.
You know, every single investment I made
that made me tens of millions of dollars
were built on the back
of a personal brand.
It built me opportunities.
It created meetings for me.
It's how I got to places.
Of course reputation matters.
It's always mattered.
People are now trying to
comprehend what's happening here
because it's become bigger
then the mainstream media.
Everybody here can be as
big as they want to be
on merit and skill and that's incredible
because we use to be gateway
and gatekeepers, right?
So, yeah, both will happen
and then you'll decide what you wanna do.
I could easily make 30
million dollars a year
being Gary V.
I choose not to because I
still wanna be a business man
and that's why I have an 800 person agency
and that's why I'm gonna have 18 Fiverrs
when I get off stage 'cause
I wanna build businesses.
I don't wanna be just a personal brand.
But that doesn't mean that's wrong.
And there's a lot of people who do that
and if that's what you wanna do,
the more awareness you have,
you will be given
something called options.
And let me promise you something,
options are good.
- Yeah, thank you Gary.
And I wanted to ask you as
well for Fiverr platform,
do you, what are your thoughts on that,
like, if we're expanding our services.
We're getting a lot of requests.
We're like top rate seller, you know,
in the top category for
social media marketing.
So, what are your thoughts
on expanding that,
going into fields like
doing production video,
maybe you know, building like a brand --
- I think you should
use it as a gateway drug
to bigger scopes.
- Okay. Thanks Gary.
And the last question, sorry for that.
But is there any chance
foreseeability to have, you know,
10, 15 minute talk to you one on one,
at some point, maybe in
your future conferences
like in Stockholm or maybe
could be just Face Time
or anything like that.
- Maybe in the back half of 18
'cause I'm fighting for
every minute right now.
But if you send me an email and say,
"I'm the Fiverr guy who
asked 47 different questions.
(laughter)
I'll see that and we'll set something up.
- Thank you so much Gary.
- You're welcome.
- Thank you, thank you so much.
(applause)
- Now there's people everywhere.
Great, we've broken the ceiling.
Who's next?
- [Host] Yeah, in the back.
- Hi.
- Hi. Hi Gary.
- I'm Christina.
- Christina, how are you?
- Thank you for being here
and I didn't know you at all
until a few days ago and
I don't think I ever --
- Thanks a lot.
- Learned to pronounce --
- Okay ...
- Your last name,
but the only thing I know about you is
I watch one single of your videos
and in that one you were talking about
one is better than zero.
- Yes.
- If you can get your
message across to one person,
it's better than to zero.
And that was at the time
when I was really dying to make videos,
but I really didn't dare
to put myself out there
because of failure for people might think.
So I did this one video and
there was one people watching
and she became my client straight away.
(stifled grin)
So I just wanted to say that.
(applause)
- That's awesome.
- And the question very briefly is like,
you know all the salesperson thing
with the email marketing
and having a lead mark net
and your London page and
building up your subscriber list,
I see a trend that people are starting
to scrap their email lists
and creating Facebook groups instead.
So have their potential
clients into Facebook groups
because that's more interactive.
You can do Lives and Q & A
and sharings and Life Coach
and stuff like that.
So I just wanted to hear
your thoughts about that
because right now I don't
where to focus my energies --
- Both.
- In my limited time.
- Yeah.
You know, like, both.
Let's talk it out.
Here's why it's important.
Remember, watch what I'm, you know,
you haven't seen as much of my content.
A big thing I say is watch what I'm doing,
not what I'm saying.
If you go to GaryVaynerchuk.com right now,
I want your fuckin' email.
I don't talk about email the
way I did in 1996, 7, 8, 9.
Because I think it's established.
I think we all understand what email is,
it's potential.
I used to have,
how many people here do
email marketing or have?
In 1997, I had an email
newsletter of 200,000 people
for wine that had 91% open rates.
Under-priced attention.
This isn't new for me.
I'm just figuring out how to articulate
what I've been doing
for the last 20 years.
That's how I built a three
million dollar business
to a sixty million dollar
business in five and half years
that had no money,
making all the right decisions.
So, here's why, yes.
What happens if Facebook groups,
organic reach,
they decided that's a new
place they need to monetize
and they kill it and now you
can't reach those people.
Like, you have to have both.
You never want to be at
the mercy of a platform
and you need to always
have insurance policies.
But people pick one or the other.
The new wave says, yes Facebook,
and they're right.
There's more attention there.
Email is spam.
Nobody is reading their email.
It's not converting the same way, right?
The old guard says I'm
not gonna trust Facebook.
You know when Facebook's you know,
newsfeed started lowering
organic five years ago,
four years ago,
they're like, aha, told you sucker.
The answer's both.
Yes and yes as I heard
somebody whisper again, right?
So again, I need everybody here,
if I leave with anything and I,
this is not,
and DRock will tell you,
this is not something that
I've been pushing very hard,
audacity.
You have audacity.
Who the fuck do you think you are?
Who the fuck do I think I am?
If you wanna live that life
that you're a fuckin' coach
and people should pay you for the shit
that's coming outta your head,
you better fuckin' do both.
(snickers)
(applause)
- That's very clear.
- I'm saying this 'cause
I wanna pressure you,
just like clearly when you saw that video,
that clicked for you,
you can't put yourself,
I never put myself in a vulnerable spot.
And just relying of Facebook
is a vulnerable spot.
But it's where the attention is,
so I hedge it with having
email and SMS and my website
and my podcast and, and, and,
and, and, and, and I'm busy.
You know, four offices,
200 million dollars in
revenue in VaynerX, right?
Like two young kids, like,
fuckin' in Copenhagen,
like a fuckin', you know like,
and so if I'm doing,
now, my ambitions may be greater,
but I'm still not gonna let
you be in a vulnerable spot
where you wake up one day
and a platform makes a change
and you're like, what happened?
People are going out of business
when they only rely on SEO
of just email or just
direct mail or just Facebook
or just Twitter.
I wish Twitter stayed number one.
I was one of the first people
to have a million followers.
It was great.
It's how a lot of you
first heard about me.
That was my first coming out moment.
I loved it.
I didn't want it to change.
I won.
You know how I won?
By spending 15 hours a day
replying to people on Twitter
for 3 1/2 years.
Do you know what that feels like
when you wake up in the morning
and you realize Twitter's
starting to lose its attention?
Do you know what I did?
I took the punch in the mouth,
I spit my tooth out
and I started building
Instagram and Facebook.
I had no choice.
So, yes it's harder.
It's more work.
But the alternative is ugly.
You wanna go work at a bank?
(chuckling)
- [Host] Thank you.
(applause)
- Is that it?
- [Host] And unfortunately now
- I'm the show stopper.
- Okay.
- And that's my part of this thing.
- I think we're going away
and coming back, right?
- Yeah. Yeah.
- I think you guys need to decide
and maybe with you guys,
is if, that when I come back
for the hour for the keynote,
you know, how much do we wanna
continue the Q & A at scale?
Because so much of what I
talk about is online to watch.
I'll let you guys decide.
I'm thrilled to talk.
I love to hear myself talk,
but I'm thrilled and feel
like there's a lot sitting,
I can feel it in the Q & A part.
So you guys decide,
you guys decide,
but thank you so much.
- Oh, you can't leave yet.
- Oh.
(applause)
- Because I have saved
actually a very great question
'til the last.
So, before I let you go have a break,
Casper has a question.
- Great.
- I just wanna ask you Gary,
let's say there's this guy
who has spent a year to plan something,
plan an event.
- Yes.
- He spent all his money.
- And he feels he has it down.
It's going and it's gonna be great
and then the day before the event,
something happens.
The email that's supposed to go out
with the last crucial information,
it goes haywire.
All of sudden we have a guy
who has received 600 emails
from the organizer of this event.
Sounds like a terrible situation, right?
- Yeah, poor guy.
- Exactly.
(laughter)
Can you give an example
of how you sometime turn something bad
into something positive?
- I had something like this happen.
So,
- I don't know.
- No, no, not how did this
something like this happen?
I had something like this happen.
- Oh okay.
- I also had an email
from Wine Library, 2007,
um nine years ago,
go out instead of once, like 87 times,
which made 11% of the list unsubscribe,
get reported to Google,
blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
And it was probably one of the best things
that ever happened to me.
Because what I did was,
in that scenario,
to try to parallel to
this make pretend guy
and what he should do,
I went on my merry,
I put things in motion to
get us back to white listed,
get the data on what happened.
I had to still run the store
'cause it was busy.
We had to get packages out.
But when that was done,
two days later,
if I recall,
on the weekend,
I sat down and I called
and emailed every single
person that was affected
for the next 31 days,
three hours here, eight hours there.
Sounds like this guy is lucky
it wasn't eleven thousand people.
Which makes me think it's
gonna be a piece of cake
to personally call ...
(laughter and applause)
Look, look.
This is super interesting.
I don't know if I wrote this
in the Thank You Economy,
which is a book I wrote,
but I definitely have said this publicly.
I believe that we expect things to happen,
that we actually don't judge
that much on the bad thing.
We judge on the thing you do next.
So much so, that I have at times
thought about doing
something slightly wrong,
not that crazy,
just because I thought the apology
would be ROI positive to the entire event.
(laughter)
So I think something
amazingly good just happened.
- [Casper] We'll see.
- We will.
- [Host] Well, you'll
get your chance later
because Gary will be back
and we will of course
talk about what will happen.
- Yeah I think the one thing
that we already thought about
was that we would very
much like these questions
and we would like to make them
as interesting for everyone as possible.
So we will make a small stand out here.
There's a small elevated stand out here
and if you feel like you
wanna ask a question,
you're more than welcome to
come and deliver your question
and we'll do a little
bit of screening before
so we make sure that it's
relevant to everyone here.
So I --
- I would also say, if I may.
Since we're just shooting
the shit up here.
As somebody who's obsessed
with Q & A so much so
that the reason I wrote
the "Ask Gary V." book
was I hoping it would be so successful
that every keynote I would
give for the rest of my life
would just be Q & A,
and it's because,
it's very interesting
and we just had a bunch
of people randomly ask.
And I think as an organizer,
there's so much,
you actually make me very happy.
You have such good intent
to try to make the question valuable.
And some people may wanna pitch or thank
or things of that nature and I get that.
But it is pretty amazing doing this
for the last year or two, more Q & A.,
how much so many of these
things are universal.
60, 70, 80% of the things
we're all dealing with,
they may have a different business,
but I think we can all
recognize in this last session,
there was so many things
that were relevant to you,
that you would have never thought to ask,
but my answer to somebody else's question
might have been the unlock that you needed
for where your head's at, so.
Also something to think about.
- [Host] Give him a hand.
(applause)
- Later.
Hey guys, in my continued
track to get feedback
to make the Vlog better,
we'd love to get insights on
what micro piece of content,
what one minute clip in today's Vlog
should I cut out and
make an Instagram post.
You get to be the post header,
forget Iris, forget Dan and forget Drock,
forget Kyle, forget Justin.
You get to pick the
one minute that we chop
and make sure you upload
your favorite parts
and we will post it on Instagram
with a shout out to whatever
Instagram handle you want.
So make sure you put the
timestamp, 3:13 to 4:13
and put your Instagram handle in there.
I'll give you a shout out on
my Instagram when we post it.
See ya.
(blues music)